hi everyone my name is Sully I'm a
software engineer at Google and today I
have Wes he's a product manager at
Google with gke
Wes I understand you've been working on
the on-prem product for Google yeah so
you know last cloud next was down in San
Francisco around July and we unveiled
Jiki on Prem which is a product that
I've been working on for quite some time
and trying to bring kubernetes or an
opinionated kubernetes installation to
an on-prem environment it's something we
heard from a lot of customers that they
really wanted to solve for hybrid
scenarios where they had workloads that
they couldn't quite move to the cloud
but they really wanted the power of gke
right all of the management features
that come with gke and they wanted to
package that up and put it in their own
environment and so we've kind of been
working on that and taking that idea
forward and you know that's sort of the
beginnings of GK on Prem that sounds
super awesome so let's dig into it a
little bit what does it actually look
like how does it work yeah so um you
know GK on Prem the fundamentals for it
are actually based a lot on open source
both open source kubernetes but a new
project that's fun up in the open source
called the cluster API so this is
something that we've gotten a lot of
help from the community
chris nova hep co has been one of the
main drivers behind the cluster api but
we brainstormed this idea long time ago
around making infrastructure declarative
and this is a really you know is kind of
a new idea at the time for kubernetes we
had like 40 or 50 installers we found
they were all sort of doing their own
thing right and we were like well is
there a way that we can take that all
the lessons we've learned around
abstracting out infrastructure making it
into a kubernetes compatible API and
provide a nicely what lightweight layer
for us to build a cluster spec right
what does a cluster look like how are
the machines provisions this all was
sort of the genesis of the cluster API
which is now forming the underpinnings
for how we build GK on Prem so GK on
Prem actually uses a lot of the
machinery that we've used in the open
four cluster API we define what we want
the cluster to look like we have a cloud
provider plug-in model right now we're
supporting VMware
using vSphere as our underlying Aya's
layer but really one of the nice
features of the cluster API is this
extensibility so you know while the
scope right now is on VMware there's
opportunity for a lot of the other cloud
providers to kind of plug in and make
Jiki unprimed run across these different
environments and what kind of capability
or is the cluster api and GK on for I'm
going to enable it's really going to
enable people to to sort of treat
clusters more like cattle is one of the
big in underpinnings of it it's like
we've been trying to say if you can
define what the shape and size of your
cluster check that into a git repo or
something like that you have sort of a
reproducible cluster and if we can
automate spinning those things up and
tearing them down and automate the idea
of adding nodes and removing nodes kind
of baking in some of the node pool
concepts that we offer in gke well this
allows us to be much more flexible and
how teams go in provision clusters quite
frankly what I've seen when I talk to a
lot of customers is they have these
clusters that are really long-lived
someone's like well I need to keep my
cluster up for two to three years
sometimes because I never want to touch
it
I just keep rolling upgrades the problem
is is that at some point you may hit
features that do require sort of a
cluster rebuild and the cluster API
really makes that process of standing up
a new cluster much easier okay so it
sounds like Google is using the cluster
API to be able to provision these
on-prem clusters it's going to enable
the power of everything we have in
Google cloud to show up in on Prem what
are some of the other components that
make up on Prem yeah so the the real
power of G key on Prem is that it's an
on-prem kubernetes product that is
managed by Google so there's this
connection back to our cloud we actually
use a lot of our cloud console and our
other container services that run inside
the cloud in order to make sure that
your cluster is healthy and also to make
sure that you can utilize a lot of the
cloud based tools that we've built for
containers things like CI CD our cloud
build product any of any of our security
products that work well G ke and treat
the GK on Prem cluster sort of as an
extension of Ava's own right like it's
just another
that runs it just happens to run inside
your data center and so if you have a
large on-premise data center you could
potentially use the cloud to burst
workloads into oh absolutely I mean
you'll start to see us really start to
invest more around Multi cluster tooling
and making these Act these actions where
it's like we can build tools that
migrate from one cluster to another you
can choose to run certain workloads in
the cloud that take advantage of things
like GPUs and CPUs or you can keep
things local for data sovereignty
regulatory compliance reasons those
types of issues features are really what
we want to light up with g/km from not
super exciting when can customers begin
to play around with us we are actively
driving towards sort of a mid 2019
release for GT on Prem we are already
working with a number of early design
customers and alpha customers getting
this deployed inside their lab
environment so yeah we're still
iterating we're still looking you know
for good feedback on it but we're
driving towards the 2019 release cool
and is that the most exciting thing that
you're excited about in the next year
absolutely right it's gonna be a big
this is honestly a you know a massive
release for Google as a company because
it really starts to sell the vision of
where we're going with true hybrid
environments and getting customers an
onboarding path onto Google father that
sounds awesome so switching gears a
little bit what are you most excited
about it coupon I really am interested
in hearing Bryan green and Tim Hawkins
talk a lot about the early days of
kubernetes you know I'm war stories I I
know I've heard a lot from Joe and Craig
and I'm kind of I'm kind of interested
to hear like how it got made inside
Google you know being a Googler for
quite some time I could I know like some
of the different groups you have to jump
through so I'm I'm really interested
checking that I think it's like later
today or something like that where
they're gonna talk about that awesome
I'm looking forward that too thanks a
lot less awesome thank you take care
[Music]